you
hey guys I just wanted to make another
quick video lesson and share some share
some practical advice how to study end
games and also how to use a really nice
built-in tools in me chess so uh so I
help you learn better it help you learn
more effectively and and engage with
different types of positions that you
might be studying so for this video I've
compiled four different positions which
are all different types of end games I
feel like most players should converts
it's possible that maybe you've seen
some of these before or maybe some of
these have happened in your own games
but what I'm going to do for this video
is go through each position and play it
out against the computer and attempt to
win without having too much time in the
clock and if you're not familiar with
Lee chess it has a really nice built-in
tool to play out any position against
the computer and to do that from a study
there's a couple ways a couple ways but
the way I'm going to do it is go to menu
continue from here and we're going to
start with the very famous knight in
Bishop checkmate I'll say play with
machine of course if you have a training
partner and you would want to play this
against a friend or whatever you can
click play with a friend and send a
challenge to someone but for now we're
gonna do see how confident am i I'll set
two minutes per side should I set one
let's say one minute per side I'm gonna
be white and I'm gonna play against the
highest level stockfish so essentially
black will play perfectly and try and
resist as much as possible and we'll
continue from here and hopefully I don't
embarrass myself and hopefully I can
convert all the positions on the first
try for now I am white and now now I
have a game a me versus stockfish I have
the King knight in Bishop I said that as
as difficult as possible where I'm
cornered so I'm gonna focus here and
I'll try and give some commentary
to try and coordinate the king and the
bishop and the night let's put the king
in the center and put the night here put
the bishop here and let's see I have to
make up some kind of waiting move let's
put the bishop here
he's kind of okay let's put the knight
here now I'm creating the barricade
and check okay
step is forcing the King into one side
of the board and actually already here I
know how to win pretty easily it's the
King King Knight Bishop roll and the
night is going to execute this w pattern
night here Bishop to
the Bishop d3 Lincoln's Bishop d3
wait a minute
I mess up no this
is okay
so also note that I have to do this in
less than 50 moves what am i doing oh I
have to okay this is not the cleanest
conversion not how much time left
let's make a waiting move okay it's hard
to do that while talking and having a
minute on the clock but I managed six
six seconds left those 40 moves
okay I'm learning that that's not so
easy to talk through with one minute
left but anyway the point of this is to
show it you can play against the
computer a little time I'm sure I could
have done better there now I'll show a
trick if I wanted to bring this back
into the study and perhaps look at all
the moments where I could have improved
I don't think people can see the URL but
I do have this URL here I would just
copy this command C and then I would go
back to the study add chapter and now I
can import the link it's great when you
when you play any sort of game on me
chess it has its own unique link paste
the link there create chapter and then I
have the whole game I play against the
computer and for this for this one I'll
just show you there's another great tool
built into lis chess which is end gamed
table base and even going back to the
initial position if you don't know why
the table bases it's essentially able to
solve any position with 6 or less pieces
on the board so in this case there's
only 4 pieces so if we turn on table
base I think my face is blocking the
blocking the button but it says opening
exploring table base click on this and
then it basically shows how long it will
take to meet actually curious here
kingi for gtz I'm not actually sure what
that witness means dtz and DTM
I know DTM is distance tool mate what is
dt z
TTC means I'm like Google this real
quick dtz a table base does this mean
you
det z-depth zeroing move Oh it resets
the 15 move count
so like a capture a pawn push
I actually don't know oh I'm not gonna
spend too much time looking into that
I'm gonna have to do some research and
and come back to that I'll probably
leave this in the video - I'm not I'm
not planning to cut up this video anyway
in any way but the point here is that if
I wanted to maybe look at some moment
like this position oh I think I know
okay so 45 is is not the number of moves
it's number of plies and essentially you
would have to divide by two to find the
number of moves so if this case white is
checkmating
oh it actually says if you hover over it
okay that's nice
made in 46 half moves so that's actually
made in 23 um sorry to spend so much
time on that but if we hover over this
let's say
next capture or pawn move
that's a bit weird
because nothing will be captured and
there's no pawns on the board so I don't
know why it says that but I guess the
DTM is a metric to focus on so in this
position a white with perfect play white
has forced mate in 29 if I can do math
58 divided by 2
now I didn't play perfectly it took me 4
you moves well that's still not bad
guess 11 moves off from from perfect
so like this position I have takes 15
more half moves till mate and I'm sure I
messed up around here did I mess up
around here anyway I didn't mess up like
grand scheme of things
Oh so we'll continue from here and we'll
look at another will do another endgame
um if I didn't want to save this for
some reason or I didn't want to include
this in the study I could just delete
the chapter very easily but then there's
no going back so anyway I I converted
King Bishop Knights let's move on to
King pawn pawn vs. King pawn pawn pawn
we're gonna continue from here play with
machine and then let's do another 1
minute game I know people like slower
chests I'm just trying to be efficient
here even though the last one was not
that efficient uh and let's crush some
stock fish
um bring the king up it's all about King
activity
he's also focusing on King activity hmm
let's do this
okay get some opposition wuji five I
think G fibers should make things a bit
easier play f4
to focus here maybe h4 h4 actually looks
nice
and then here
h3a my is not winning this no I'm still
winning this I should be winning this
be winning
it's better be winning to put the pawn
each five
not winning this
mess-up
I'm gonna flag to
you
this is so embarrassing I have shown
students this
oh I'm not winning this
wait a minute
I made him move the pawn
ah it's a draw no like now I can't flag
okay
oh that was so bad well now I learned
something stock fish defended well
analysis board so the now so sport
brings us to what's not the study and I
don't think the saves but I can get some
quick feedback that was really
unfortunate I think this is just oh hey
this winning
I can play h5 how is this winning king
of 7f for
here I'm just being lazy
this is
so this is a winning idea
age six I guess then if King ah five I
can run around and I'm just in time his
King f6 only winning move and the black
king is boxed out
okay well that's an interesting one to
know so if the pawns on each seven it's
much more difficult to win if the one
way around each six is easier anyway let
me try and redeem myself I'll go back to
starting position
I clearly need to do this again um now
I'm not getting the continue from here
button because I think I'm on analysis
board I'll just do it the other way we
can go to board editor and then continue
from here
play with machine I can will do one
minute and okay good luck I'll start
with g3 this time bring the king up
okay G for what a move
what is he doing this should be winning
better not be drawn already
like f3 take take
I'm gonna try and trick him his
stockfish it's hard person to trick
this is already drawn
this is so sad
I resign lets me resign that no black
has no meaning material I guess I still
able to resign I deserve to lose that so
again I'm I'm running into the almighty
stock fish
for a longer video I would I would go
and try and decipher it what did I do
wrong I guess this is already a long
video so what to do
oh this is just wrong yeah
difficult
each three is losing yeah okay board
editor I don't know if I'm going to
upload this this is too embarrassing
continue from here play with machine
this time I'm going to give myself two
minutes so I'm clearly not the amazing
chess player that I thought I was um oh
I don't want to continue okay I want to
modify the position a little bit
okay continue from here play with
machine two minutes
I have to work my way up to playing with
one minute and I'll play whites okay now
I have time to think let's start with f4
I'm going to prevent any g5 shenanigans
and play g4
the best way
Roach things
it's a pawn on g6 so I'm not taking any
risk here
each five never works because I can take
so now I'm shouldering the key the
shouldering or opposition whatever it's
called
g6 is a good move
I guess I could get into that because
and I had earlier
I know f55 is probably drawing
okay let's go around like this
that doesn't do anything though to go
back
position
wait a minute I might have this and then
this and then this
let's try this
five
could also play h5 potentially
let's play h5 first
oh man did I mess this up
I think I'm winning because I can use
that same idea I used last time
here that doesn't work
so maybe I do this
six way Kingi six doesn't work
what is this maybe this
work either
you
this is so sad
I thought this was going to be easier
I'm gonna end the video here I'm so
frustrated right now
and this goes to show okay um I wanted
to record a nice short video on how to
convert simple end games but apparently
this is not that simple
maybe after I have to come up with like
a video lesson how to convert this end
game that's my goal
okay oh I didn't even get to the next
two positions that I had from previously
if I go back to the study where is a
study is it this one no
okay it's this one um so I have to I
have to do some homework and I'll come
back and I will try harder next time but
I'm gonna end it there hopefully this
was instructive for people hopefully now
people at least have some tools to
better work on their games and I guess
my downfall here was overconfidence and
yeah that's life
bye guys